[Music]
the winners and champions of Dancing
with the Stars athletes are Adam and
Jenna even though he didn't bring home
the mirror ball he gotta feel good with
how win tonight that's okay we feel
wonderful we made it this far we went
out we achieved what we wanted to we did
to clean programs and I know how to
dance
and I have really good friends now for
life what was the hardest aspect about
having the shortened season you know the
hardest aspect would be getting to know
your partner so quickly you have to
really adapt very quickly and you know
usually we get one track and it's like
it starts off with like a minute minute
and ten seconds straight off the bat you
know she was doing one minute and thirty
numbers she was doing two numbers two
eliminations three eliminations it's it
was cutthroat it was hard it was ten
weeks in four weeks the end of the day
did the right person win the Mirrorball
trophy yes yes absolutely I mean they
brought it home every week and Adam has
wonderfulness partner I mean they
deserved it anything you would have done
before
absolutely nothing nothing you guys
killed it you really did tonight was
your night I think in many ways
congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]